the prophet Muhammad s. wasallam told us
whoever builds a mosque for Allah Allah
will build for him a similar house in
jenah and we know the great reward that
will not only be gained but rather will
fill your grave after your death
whenever someone prays there whenever
someone gives Shada in the Masid
whenever someone learns something in the
Masid yes that will be something that
you will have on your scale
[Music]
how are you guys
doing I recently came across an
interesting part of a discussion between
KT Hopkins and Andrew Tate for those who
don't know Katy Hopkins is effectively
one of like the right-wing Ultra
right-wing outcasts islamophobes call
her what you want to call her she has a
very bad record
and she's talking to Andrew Tate
alhamdulillah became Muslim but now has
been kind of I don't know you could say
allying a little bit too much in my
opinion with the rightwing or the far
rightwing speaking to these guys in a
positive manner which uh I don't like
that but let's take a look at some of
this video and come back and respond in
kind some of the best countries on the
planet today are the first world Islamic
Nations the safest places you can
possibly be with 0% taxes and you can
invest your money safely and you can
live a very peaceful life and your
children will not be taught anything
weird if you lived in Qatar or Bahrain
or Kuwait or Dubai or where do you live
I currently live in Romania why do you
live in Romania is Romania is a
Christian land I noticed it is why is
that then well I moved here a long time
ago and no Andrew why don't you live in
an Arab land well let's see what happens
once I'm uh you just told me fre you
won't live there you're going to come to
Britain and probably hang around with me
save the population perhaps but my point
being now my point is why don't you live
in a Muslim land I would be very happy
to live in Dubai so why don't you cuz I
can't oh yeah no I know you have a
restraining thing here and that's
pathetic and we know about that but you
would choose Romania anyway as we
discussed at the top of this
conversation because you like the feel
here you like the freedom here you like
the masculinity here which I feel but
you wouldn't choose to live in a Muslim
land well it's actually interesting
because you say it's that interesting
when you're thinking of how you're going
to respond and you don't directly
respond to my question why don't you
live in a Muslim I'll directly respond
I'd like that me as a man I find Eastern
Europe appealing for the reasons you
have said yes however if I were to raise
my family or one of my families or if I
were to have to in a worst case scenario
leave my family unattended Les say I
were to put my children and my wife in a
house I would choose a first world
Islamic Nation all day long they're not
going to learn anything stupid in school
they're going to be physically safe they
can be provided for with staff and help
and they're going to be very well looked
after and I know they're completely fine
I would never leave my child and my wife
alone in London ever I'd be by their
side permanently because it's a failed
country and even here in Eastern Europe
although I think it's safe it's a very
much a man's world and a woman by
herself might struggle to navigate it I
believe I could buy a mansion in Dubai
and put a wife and three children in
Dubai and I could go away for six months
and come back and they'd be perfectly
fine well it's very interesting here
because she tried to Corner him and this
is the thing Andrew and I want to say
this to you directly brother yeah and
I've got your number of course but
sometimes you're busy I'm busy and we
can't communicate on WhatsApp so I'm
going to say this very clearly this
little thing that she did there this
little underhand where she tried to
catch you yeah this is
emblematic of something greater that the
far right have in store for you bro
these people are not going to be loyal
these people are not loyal to you people
like Tommy Robinson and KT Hopkins and
these kinds of people they're not loyal
when you are a member of a fraternity a
religious fraternity like Al Islam we
are bound
byah the proposition that there's no God
worthy of worship except for one God
that's what we're Bound by we're Bound
by something transcendental something
greater than ourselves we're Bound by
the purpose of life we're Bound by the
reason for our
existence when you got people like KT
Hopkins and Tommy Robinson who I know
full well because I'm taking Tommy
Robinson to court by his own admission
he's received the legal papers people
like that weak cowards who when they're
confronted one-on-one get slapped in the
face there's videos of him getting
slapped in the face in luten by one
individual one guy slapping him in the
face and him not even responding to that
yeah when you're allying or speaking or
being friendly to people like that just
wait because what happens is when they
get a chance they'll throw you under the
bus that's when you have an allegiance a
an allegiance that is based not on the
transcendental not on the purpose of
life not on these kind of things but
what I will say Andrew is to be honest I
think you've done a good job in
circumnavigating it she
wasn't tactful enough I watched a video
of him actually Andrew Tate there was
like a a kickboxing fight where he was
fighting like a
20-year-old and this thing here a
20-year- old but he was very like
impassioned and he was very like you
know eager and in the first round he was
given Andrew trouble and stuff like that
in the second round Andrew kind of tamed
him and I think he knocked him out in
the second round and this is something
great about Andrew it's it's it's a
feature both in his debating skills and
his fighting he's able to regain
composure quite quickly when he's under
pressure he lets people try it and then
he kind of allow it's it's a style it's
a tactic it's a
strategy he lets them try it go for it
all right okay say no more and then
afterwards he comes and he finishes the
job in this case Katy Hopkins tried to
take him down she tried to to deliver a
kind of decisive blow and what Andrew
done was he he he posited a an excellent
counter argument okay which is basically
the argument from socioeconomics yeah so
the argument is basically this is that
those who are in a higher standing in
terms of socioeconomics or who have more
money are less likely to commit crimes
there's less likely to be problems and
so on and so forth and that by the way
is a basic analysis that can be applied
uh internationally can also be implied
within a country so internationally in
the sense
that you can see countries acting with
each other in that way and in a country
like you would if you want one predictor
of who's going to commit the most crimes
is those who are most impoverished and
disenfranchised and poor it doesn't
matter what race religion or ethnicity
they are and it just so happens for
example in the UK there's a lot of
working-class Muslim people therefore
you'll find disproportionate numbers
according to prison statistics for
example of Muslim people according to
the population desperate to the
population in prisons because there's a
disproportionate number of
disenfranchised Muslims or working-class
Muslims in the UK for example so what he
was making was an excellent point and it
was very it's very difficult to arue
against that point so she retreated okay
so it's kind of reminiscent of that time
the young 20-year-old tried to knock out
Andrew Tate in the first round and then
he kind of dodged it and he knocked him
out in the second but the bigger point
to be made here is that allying yourself
with the far right okay I have to be
honest with you is going to be a big
mistake and a bigger mistake is trying
to please everyone because to try and
please the Muslim Community while
simultaneously trying to please the
farri right while simultaneously trying
to be a pro Trump supporter while trying
to simultaneously being in the good
books of Elon Musk what all that
together what you will do is you will
actually when you try and please
everyone you end up pleasing no one all
of them will drop you and you could look
at what happened with Jordan Peterson
just look at his views I was looking on
his uh channel the other day man he had
like 40,000
50,000 numbers sorry to say sorry to say
and it's not coincidental that that
happened after he dropped the Muslim
Community where he done it
conscientiously he kind of like threw
them under the bus after we welcomed him
with Open Hands him and his family and
his daughter and everybody he tried
dropping us and the only thing that got
dropped is his views so what happened is
this is that you not only Fade Away into
relevance but you endanger looking
unprincipled so in some therefore I will
say that um I think that when you align
yourself with a community like the
Muslim Community and you align yourself
purposefully and mean meaningfully
you'll find loyalty until you die
because we're bound together by Iman
faith and it goes all the way to the
Grave better than being connected to
people like KT Hopkins of all people and
that's what I've got to say
was hey you are you wasting your time on
social media again your brothers and
sisters in Islam net from Norway are
establishing a Masid a DA Center
establishing a Masid to convey the
message of Islam is one of the best
Deeds a Muslim can do there's a huge
need for it in Norway you know this and
I know this so that makes the reward
even greater so give generously and
Allah will give you even more